when i saw the sketch i was like you
know what this looks like a dress i
haven't seen before and i loved the
different colors the combination
it felt it just felt like me because
also there's something about it that
feels very old hollywood it is you know
i was about to say that same thing yeah
it has sparkles which is very me
i love it how you feeling tonight so
happy i'm so happy to be here like
first of all the category i'm in with
nicole and olivia and kristen and
penelope i mean these women are
phenomenal we've all spoken during this
experience you sent them flowers correct
yes but also nicole sent me champagne
like we all face it's like the most
incredible group of women and kristen
and i've been text it's just so special
so i um i'm excited to just be here and
celebrate with these women i fall in
love with you a little more every time i
see you because i saw when you first
came out the first place you went to the
fans the first place you went was to say
thank you and hello like why does that
sit in your space
those people are the only reason i get
to do what i
do and i'm going to get emotional
talking about it but
also a lot of people storytelling
helps us through dark times and we're
coming out of a dark time right i mean
this is the first time i get to see
everyone's faces in a long time we've
been wearing masks and so to be together
to be out of this time of isolation and
separation i just wanted to remind them
how and thank them
uh
and remind them for how loved they are
so okay have you thought about at all
real quick about when that envelope is
opened have you thought about that have
you tried to process any of it there's
the reality and she's gonna i i am
pretty convinced
my name is not gonna be called
but so i am so excited to celebrate no
no no i've been screaming
don't know listen you guys tell me the
saga i really i'm not the person who
shows up and goes oh it's me it's
absolutely not me so i'm happy to
celebrate because every single one of
these women
they're like my goddesses so i'm so
happy